les joueurs du mls gp peuvent laisser
éclater leur joie après deux matches
accrochés face à issoudun ils sont
arrivés à remonter leurs deux points de
retard dans ce 32e de finale pourtant ce
dimanche lui mais rien n'a été simple
malgré une bonne première période le
score n'est que de 18 à 13 à la pause et
le spectre d'une élimination est encore
présent première mi-temps bien en place
mais dominer n'est pas gagner on a deux
temps forts on doit être meilleur pour
concrétiser les points
on est un peu dans le dur la 20e 22e
minute on n'arrive pas à concrétiser nos
temps forts des temps forts non
concrétisées qui aurait pu coûter cher
dans cette seconde période issoudun
passe devant les immuno à quelques
minutes de la fin du match sur cette
action mais les joueurs de frédéric
jardin réagissent et réussissent à
marquer un nouvel essai score final 26 à
23 le mls gpu chaud mais se qualifie
pour les seizièmes de finale très très
très croisé restait un gros match contre
une très belle équipe d'issoudun et
voilà c'était très dur jusqu'à la fin du
match et puis on a bien réussi à passer
devant et à se qualifier pour les 13
euros c'est que c'est ma première phase
finale en seniors du coup très heureux
de vivre ça avec le groupe et on va tout
faire pour elle plus loin possible au
prochain tour le club yvelinois
affrontera l'équipe du ris sommes basés
dans les départements du puy-de-dôme un
match attendu depuis le début de la
saison par le mlsgp c'était l'objectif
du club c'était d'arriver se propage de
monter pour pouvoir va espérer monter si
on rate le coche on aura une deuxième
lame même si je préfère passer par la
porte la plus courte dire le premier
match qui nous attend la semaine
prochaine pour essayer d'aller justement
d'inverser la pression sur le premier
match il retourne pas faire ce qu'il
faut pour monter directement le match
aller est programmé ce dimanche 15 mai à
l'extérieur et leur tour sera organisé
dans le 78 le 22 mai prochain